um remember what happened last time
yeah I [ __ ] rocked it laughs last
time I got the final plug I avoided
dying or getting severely injured I
think I took one lick from a licker
so I have all the plugs and I have
what's my home fixing and I'm on
cautions I'm not doing super great
ah that's terrible and I got a bunch of
guns - let's check them out I got some
serious heat now I got a machine gun
that's pretty hot and I got a magnum
I love of the machine gun has a
percentage yeah I'd actually tell you to
take a machine gun
oh alright because you could take the
Magnum but recommend a machine gun
so here's the thing it's feels likely
that if you want me to take that that I
should take better ABS now here's I'm
thinkin I'm gonna have to pass spider
den to use those plugs I think which
means I should probably take this blue
herb and combine them what do you think
about that because this is my last blue
herb and then the only herb I have left
is this is this mixed herb good shape
you're coming up with some health should
I get I can't carry all these plugs
unless I get rid of something there's
another saver map for this bike okay so
so two spiders yeah I would ya know what
please go on I think how much space in
you right now I don't even know if you
need the shotgun in yeah
I think I passed Dwight I would say just
leave the shotgun am i was winging the
spiders yeah boy the spiders actually
don't worry about like you can worry
about item stuff remember when they ran
on the walls yeah I remember how do I
know which wall they're gonna do do you
just pick a side and pray there he'll
already be on the first one I already be
on the wall yeah but remember they're
like like they run really quickly donut
okay so which way i'ma go in taking
these yeah I'm just close when that
one's event too small for Leon he call
me fat
yeah it's like body armor so it's all
bulk muscle called fitting Mass Street
math he's building math cultivating mass
cultivating mass you've been like
holding your limbs for a good amount of
time this is what you were mentioning
before is it's like my hip my - stomach
itches thank you my ribs
oh I lost my good shot my ribs they do
it fast
my stomach itches oh I'm hungry tell me
Tom Tom rubs what does it look like when
you go from behind I think we both know
I guess you just did I know I love the
pain
oh yeah give me a liquor upset myself
yeah yeah yeah and me I did everyone all
right
since going you could go check out what
happened to that dude in the cells if
you wanted to sure eyeball guy yeah like
I could forget eyeball guy guy ball guy
his little tentacle veins I'm not sure
what they were eyeball tongues coming up
on Halloween yeah should do like a
Halloween special yeah figure so good
you'll actually might yeah I don't
totally Aires I don't know if he'll be
done but you're getting there getting
there the time I think you'll be done by
the time Halloween you'll be done will
be done recording once Halloween hits I
don't know if they'll be published all
right so I need to go in here right you
go check it out what was this again just
about you
looks like important stuff
well I hope this works out for me
yikes oh man keep it live do you still
hear me come on your bangs look the same
color hair I almost got the story far
uglier than you Ben Ben Ben take Empire
Strikes Back beginning bitter irony the
Chief of Police co-conspirator
what a scoop that scum make him hang in
there don't you go dying on me get back
in yourself
get in yourself oh that was a cricket
little cricket
that thing just open a door I don't know
she'd even step on it
we lost the mansion lab facility due to
the actions of the renegade operative
Albert Wesker fortunately his
interference will have no lasting
effects upon our continued virus
research the only present concern is the
presence of the remaining stars members
Redfield Valentine Burton chambers and
Vickers if it comes to light that the
stars have any evidence as to the
activities of our research dispose of
them in such a manner that would appear
purely accidental continue to monitor
their progress and make certain their
knowledge does not go public and that
will continue to be your contact
throughout this affair just put the gun
in their hand a net you logic bastard
who are you looking at I'm over here
sorry I'd had corrective lenses she
didn't even comment on Ben's mangled
corpse oh hi Leon I saw you took both
the side pack and the machine gun you're
a jerk can you meet me there
I should I check it yeah oh I thought I
got something alien check it sellout
let's check his sellout that seems say
my name say my name there's no reason
for you to have that song in your head
you're totally right I don't know nollie
was referenced at all is there the other
cell has a blue I think it does too I'm
gonna combine these two first come VIN
combine come in nice okay so those
spiders getcha do not party unless you
do something that scares ya wise words
from Robert California okay so I'm doing
this green and a blue mm-hm if you eat a
blue does it help your health at all no
just curious boys bomber because that I
I'm pretty positive just here's poison I
don't think there's any like tiny effect
on um cuz like I'm running out of plants
here like I'm not doing so hot it's a
bit alarming how likely it is that I'm
going to get injured again alright what
am i doing
Oh into the kennels is to turn around go
into that hole
did I kill I killed all the dogs pretty
sure I'm like oh the two that were in
there yeah I'm like pretty anti dog now
did your dog scare you at home no he's
cute as a button but he does like he's
he's going through a really bad stint
right now where he likes waking up
around like 2 or 3 in the morning yeah
just like walking around on the bed
making noise and oh [ __ ]
let's go okay
you're good I think it doesn't look
great
least you've got that blue ganj okay I'm
not poisoned
but I am on caution so what don't do
anything
nothing you'll be I you feel nervous
about this okay you'll be good so I get
your machine for the same room okay I
can equip oh right because I met I have
to pass all those goddamn zoms mm-hmm
all right got it got it here we go what
zombies pretty tired with all of them Oh
Pitt went through the door no that's
upstairs so window don't I go through
there
no that's upstairs this is a third
beside the plug room coming up but what
room I mean we could have brought the
plug those in earlier which sucks but
whatever we could have plugged the
nursery here this time
bring-bring
a shrubbery do [ __ ] not too big not too
small it's nice to be good
all right you do need the valve handle
coming up but I don't think it's yet
trying to think if you want it now I
don't know I do I want to know mmm do I
get rid of these plugs when I plug them
in yeah
then it doesn't really hurt me I don't
know you're good just I'll say no let's
do it gonna suck if you need that valve
handle I'm gonna be mad at you if I need
that valve handle because I had room for
it I had every opportunity in the world
all right where am I going to the I
shaped room capital I don't know maybe
yeah I think so I don't think you know
anything now this one I think I left a
zambian do you wishing out I forgot I
left a zombie in here 100%
no I didn't so you're saying take I'm
100%
oh my god it's an I'm an only friend
yep he's vomiting she gone that sucker
yeah use that I'm not injured
I don't not poisons still can use help
precaution
I would go give yourself the space how
you're the left and then shoot back this
way
isn't that a dead end well this is to I
guess like you're not gonna go past it
it's just hanging off of me how do I get
it off
I aim down at them VSR you should you
can aim down what you yelled at me once
when I aim down remember well that was
for like you didn't get that far
I didn't yell at you when I told you
like tame down for like getting down for
liqueurs but you aim down yeah you don't
need to ain't down for dogs he seems
like on the ground walkers so next time
you're just like alternate between him
that's the noise he makes maybe you only
K by the spider design you'll be better
now do I need to watch that cutscene
again probably the one of the you don't
have to go there I don't know unless you
want that blue herb I think I have one
so I think I'm okay without it ray yeah
I got one I'm okay just take come by
that blue er no I don't even combine
that blue orb why you don't well don't
come on it yet if you don't get poison
then don't even use it you just do all
this no cuz I'm not coming back then I
don't like to go to another pick up that
blue earth though for Ben I wasn't gonna
go in there I'm going all the way
but I've turn over what happens like if
you think like if you don't consequence
for not talking to Claire on the
walkie-talkie that's the dog
no that's the dog alleyway oh [ __ ]
you're in the die [ __ ] you're right
that's not that wasn't the dog the dog
Ali what this is the doggy at what you
want to go to dog Ali wait that was the
event for someone smaller oh my
mighty have fallen Jill Valentino I mean
I can see her it's not like it hurts me
like it little why care it's like ten
extra second let's do it Wow okay I
think it was past parking lot all the
way down it's all coming together now
parking lot seems like kind of a waste
of space like there's a lot of room here
and I'd do much here mm-hmm except
remove that car that one time but with a
da is that her nickname yeah I'm coming
in baby start button I also I'm afraid
too because this is the Japanese ps3 and
sometimes they push buttons they are
what I think they are like the entire
the entire actual interface circle is
select and it's just a mindfuck yeah
it's dumb
like my armpit
burning or it feels like there's an
alien about to burst out of it here
comes a da what the [ __ ] was that god
what was that
good God
reddit william birkin huh
that guy's a jerk where are you going
ada to the chemical plant I have a
feeling that's where I'll find John ADA
wait she's so unhelpful you read me
Claire we now have access to the back of
the parking lot I'm getting out of here
and heading to the sewer can you meet me
there
let's go yay
yo all right let's slow so didn't not
awkward anymore Leon's probably thinking
about it he's not Hayes watch no not if
it validates
these brakes are very nicely laid only I
was going wrong oh crap I forgot how
spiders how do I avoid this one like
this and then left you nice Wow Jukes
tight tight tight
deploy so yeah for this dude coming up
okay so I have to do it a Daffy blend of
down and up
Daffy blend yes Daffy death Daft Punk
blend oh that's what I'll sound like
when I'm shooting it all right
I ran got it totally here we go not
gonna die cuz they're like attached to
my groin like leeches you know like it's
actually really hard to get a mafia once
they're attached you know it looks like
a butt yeah what were you gonna say
we will fight them up
get it
suck it this time move
I hope you like bullets do these dead
does he come back I don't know go check
it out
go touch him go poke him with you he's
alive go poke him with your gun he's a
he looks alive but the music is an
honorable case no I don't know I think
he's I don't know I don't I don't want
to die what do I do
run away and then shoot down like can I
go through the store just run away and
then shoot down down now [ __ ] Jay make
sure you don't need to heal you [ __ ]
little [ __ ] should I combine or just
eat this no I just eat that and then run
keep running left and then turn around
look down and shoot them those [ __ ]
if they take me down again be really mad
god damn it alright emptied like an
entire wars worth of rounds into those
things they've fought in Vietnam by
yourself with other bullets live all the
people I was fighting in Vietnam were
really small and drag down the third row
up on me Oh taking them out whatever I
lived you almost did it without taking
you hell that probably should have not
made you go near him anyway those plugs
in yo plug those holes oh right it was
over here they inspect the monster I
hope he has a plant on him cuz I could
really use one
you just want to make sure there was any
others little shits that could come and
hurt me many a person is like survivor
fighting then died from the little ones
at the end yeah I could have been
putting these plugs in one at a time no
you could have done three to ten bears
just like a sucker King me
god I hope there's a plant in here yeah
star wars there what no is looking
really disease not see that coming she
just fell out of the [ __ ] ceiling did
well I wish I could answer every room
like that stupid shut up defend yourself
I was an officer it's my job to look out
for you it's like nuts
it's like watching Ken and Barbie have
an argument yeah and is severely injured
and Barbie is just I mean oddly like
confident with everything I bet I need a
valve and I keep walking this way
I will
/ / / / ticking man does I didn't mean
to do that
I didn't think that was a door I could
go in well shall we proceed
Wow
m'lady please grab my gun other one no
they're all blue what you guys there for
now really actually now take those you
got space
I don't need blue I'm not about to fight
a a poisoning guy yeah yeah what happens
if I combine two blue super poison power
don't think nothing point so this is the
save room
got the lockers thesaurus stick on the
first and third Wednesday of the month
Angelica Margaret chief of mission first
names never trust him we'll make use of
the facilities be sure to reduce the
moisture levels in the facility by
activating the fan as equipment we'll be
using the susceptible weight he will be
she will be using as susceptible to the
effects of water vapors Don Weller will
be using the facility the chemicals will
be transferred on he will be transported
dong Weller are extremely volatile
extreme caution should be used by dong
Weller
on the 6th and 16th of every month
police chief brian irons will leave
visit the facility on the fourth Friday
of every other month William Birkin will
use the facility to conduct a training
seminar or umbrella you will be informed
of all other how do I need to know this
Charles Coleman otherwise known as Chuck
cold man
Don Weller Chuck cold man and jela
Margaret it's all coming to jello
Margaret that's not what I said I said
Angelica Margaret jelica jello Margaret
and Don Weller what can I steal for
those lockers anywho maybe that toolbox
yes hey Tony I got some guns for you no
those are bullet he's got some bullets
for you imagine if every time a couple
more in car bombs you shot something you
shot like a tiny gun out of a gun take
the valve this time do I need Duggal a
blue machine should I do the shotgun
just looking for a little while I feel a
lot better with it though yeah just just
in case and a mom
should find health sooner just you only
that makes herbs I really wonder if you
should save now after no now you're good
other increments next to that
typewriters oh I will I'll put those in
my little safe box for a future on my
way outta it is ADA
I was joking before mmm on the left side
hard to tell oh thank you
I mean I how many do I have now four
three three it's not that many well not
more than enough but you've got those
two up in the zombie hallway if like
worst comes to worst right let's find
out with our handy-dandy
nope oh I know okay I think I know it
was all right um there's this no no go
back go pretty positive okay go over to
these lockers I think you can get on the
side and push them oh that is it could
we even think of a different room
no it is this one I think
yeah wow that's oh wait even yeah you
might even need to do it yeah go check
this out this is impressive
well the map also had no alcove that's
what it might be yeah my way a tough one
you and your really nice shoulder blades
we take me stick me spider alley because
I don't want to go there I hope you like
hell I don't like this where am I in the
warehouse the sewer basement - there's
items I do I could I could use it to see
actually is there [ __ ] in here like zoms
like that lamp I think those are called
alcohol lamps that's what they call him
here I do need to use it
press a X on I want it or whatever but
it is yeah I remember that comb some
weird oh yeah I really just want to
plant honestly that's what I'm this
entire game you're fired shotgun shows
my grandfather just died none flush with
cash
I think the Manson's over there
is there another um alcohol yes very
cool
Magnum mm-hmm
this has been really helpful wow they
really really give you ups for finding
secrets in this game don't they I think
there's memory serves there's what
you're looking for I think but we're I
mean I can just walk around touching
everything I have no fear problem with
that there's like first-aid spray
somewhere soon really that would great
first aid spray sounds cool try the
Shelf gonna make your like facing it
more okay just walking into [ __ ] it's
their fault for designing a game that
made me do this
okay they're mine freaking dog dude
clearly said there was stuff in there
huh Jesus enough I could have [ __ ]
stabbed you get this those Magnum
bullets yeah I should store those
which I store anything else
actually keyring keep in case am I going
to spider alley again
hate it spider alley I actually was
going through rattlesnake path no don't
go through there's a elevator next to
the door I didn't know okay where's Mike
well grab that other blue wear it and
put it in the air mine too this happens
so quickly check it it yeah just in case
something that goes wrong hate us stay
here oh wait no come I know it's a are
you digging both of them you got both
the last time I guess
oh yeah it was right before a save room
that makes sense damn it Mike stay here
Adel let's go wait no state us to here
Mike let's go just me
okay so this is
see you later loser well this is awkward
Oh
she's holding a gun
Leon
that woman was I have to talk to her
that Birkin woman did he get shot yeah
she just has to talk to her even though
she he got shot yeah wait I'm super
confused I'm shot and she's gonna go
talk to a lady
mm-hmm and I got shot dodging to save
her mm-hmm it sucks way I shouldn't go
in there we come back to our the camera
did you come in through here is Leon
anyway spiders I'm shooting them I like
I'm not taking any more risks to spiders
locusts how's me health
didn't say do it oh good shot or did you
miss I was aiming for your head I'm
drunk identify
ada ada wong ada wall I've heard that
name before
now I remember one of the men from
Chicago who came to assist the t-virus
Chicago his girlfriend's name as his
password the biggie the Big Easy how did
you know who are you
Big Apple Birkin my husband is the man
responsible for the creation of the
t-virus William Birkin what John's dead
he became one of those zombies my
condolences I won't let anyone touch I
cast a spell on you g-virus
wait we're capable of creating the
ultimate bioweapon we just learned about
the t-virus
yeah get used to that you know there are
few more in the series creature in the
police department is precisely my
husband William yeah
none of this would have happened if they
hadn't tried to steal his research away
from him she's got some cojones yeah
this guy's [ __ ] it's hunk and pal this
way this way
it's sheer perfection
my precious Jeannie virus oh we going
back in time you will ever take you away
from me hello we're here to take the
g-virus away so you finally come doctor
we're here to collect the g-virus sample
sorry but I won't just
the sample that's it all right
okay let's move out
my man hold on darling I'm taking care
of that bullet wound first that variable
that very particular one
Alpha Team have to retrieve the sample
get Roger
so endanger your wife
are you telling me that he injected the
g-virus into his own body a G virus has
the ability to revitalize cellular
functions
I have a lot of cellular functions
myself oh they're hot
wait it's eating more of them what is
this thing
many scream oh the rats
so those rats were the carriers of the
virus as a result of his virus induced
transmutation William should have lost
love that she knew have not seen as does
he tell she knew that even worse
respire weapon including William as the
ability to implant embryos into other
creatures and create offspring
fight she's got huge hand
mhmmm Club her without their Hg can I
give my spray to me no I don't think so
unless you pick up anything new you do
thing am i I want to I don't even know
where I am or what I'm doing
what do you think trip back the hiney
for now the rest of these rooms right
now sorry yet like this area cuz like I
accomplished what I went out to
accomplish I talked to check that boo
check that body missing from when Leon
comes here yes let's go down down the
dirt okay like I did it I talked to that
lady and then I killed her so I did all
those things that I was you're totally
right actually so I'll go down in case I
remember there might be something she
could do
you just lost ADA ADA Fong it's might be
actually a good time to save to go back
and save close to actually check down
the highway first I'd like to just see
my health real fast okay go ahead which
I went I was down the other way back
yeah oh wait no sorry that's where you
came from
yes it is yeah toward the camera so you
want to go there savory but yes no that
is the way you came from okay I don't
know where we are though that's where
you came from
check so check the other letter where
she went
right right left I can't do anything
yeah I would save okay I'm actually
short ish episode but that's a good no I
think it's just good because like people
have said this before like oh these ones
were short but we do it based on the
save discs because you definitely don't
I don't want to get stuck good I killed
that i guy we're not having a lot of
health as I'd like more health items
like I'd I'd really like a little bit
more healthier
yeah like um resonable for that beat now
certain games will be easier to like we
have to decide like four five are we
both playing yeah I don't want to play
anything that has to player I think you
should play too all right six is gonna
be long fly through they'll be
entertaining to make fun of a lot of
that burning through it cool sweet we're
getting there we are getting there and
then for Halloween week maybe the
penultimate possibly recording it at
least alright see you guys next time on
Resident Evil